there's no limits you know that don't
let the word I ever put limits on you
don't move to make sure too fast just
like don't go to tomorrow too fast
he said King I can't fight you I gotta
fight my fight I was so pissed off I
said I got it
I said I got it I don't need to give you
everything you want I just make I got to
make sure you have everything you need
right now you're gonna write it you know
let's just subconscious mind be the
leader of you every footstep that's
everything why you've been on this earth
it's accounted for blame right or not
he's a former American football player
who played his entire 17-year career
with the Baltimore Ravens he was
selected to thirteen propos plain middle
linebacker his entire career he's
considered one of the greatest of all
time and his position his Ray Lewis and
here are his top ten rules for success
there's between you you efforts say
about X's and O's because long as you
play this game you're gonna mess up
plays what makes me how do I stand up
what makes the coaches notice me all
these different people some kind of
cookie then every time the coach
something what's it called in my name
woe is me fastest I'm the baby's name is
wrong
never happened honestly that there's no
difference the way you win it the way
that I went at the game business as hard
as I went at the game you know I study
businesses and I studied people as much
as I studied people trying to figure out
plays you know so it's kind of something
I told the kids yesterday you know when
you see transition really start to
happen when you really want to
transition to something master there's
no limits you know that don't let the
word I will put limits on you you could
do anything you want to do but make sure
if you have a vision make sure the
vision is written you know make sure you
have something to actually chase and not
just hoping and wishing and all these
different things so if I tell guys it's
all the time put your plans together and
be work the plan don't-don't-don't work
somebody else's plan right that's one
thing about the leak I love the leak but
the league is someone else's brand right
you have to create your own brand
yourself and your brand is whatever you
feel like doing whatever your heart is
passionate about chase it I've had I've
had seasons where I've had the worst
surgeries ever
and I've been through I had seven
surgeries you know and and that alone
you know you you ask yourself time and
time again how do you bounce back from
that year and yeah but I've always used
it as you know taking that time to
strengthen myself I never knew I was
gonna play 17 years and then who could
have ever thought that you don't you
don't see when you come into the league
you don't say you know what I'm gonna
play something to you and you don't even
think of it that way you just say I take
a year-by-year and that's what I try to
tell kids don't move to next year too
fast just like don't go to tomorrow too
fast deal with today do it right now you
know we'd be in a locker room that we
are practice and I'm like listen put the
phones out because these moments go go
too fast and when they go on they're
going you know so before you look up
you're in two three five seven ten
twelve if you make it that long well
because most of them don't you know just
like you spoke about early most of these
young babies never see five years never
see seven years never let left in your
career you know so you try to prepare
them to understand what the moment
actually feels like and that's why I
think honestly why my career last so
long because I always lived in the
moment like it nothing else mattered to
me and I was selfish at times because
even towards my family nothing else
mattered when it came to that when he
came to that I was dialed there it's a
it's a heck of a blessing to be here now
I'm walking I'm healthy you see but
still making an impact absolutely right
absolutely so you know I I just tell
people I don't know how long whoever's
gonna play but I will say enjoy every
moment
don't don't rush too fast you know let
your years take care of her years but go
year by year go day by day go hour by
hour go meant about a minute never
research something what to do everybody
do one thing I want you to research sort
of Blake David and Goliath I want you to
understand what the King told David and
said when he put on the armor on David
and he said I want you to fight the
light but this armor because he's huge
he's nine foot tall and David says
something that was very key to the king
he said King I can't fight your fight I
got to fight my fight
it's about fighting our fight 2005 I had
one who's tried to injuries ever and I
couldn't help my team so the labels took
away so that could be doubt but if you
still have a live-in job cycle you got
to rally around about loyalty it's the
top understanding I'm gonna make the
play on the watch the play be made it's
simple it see if I could tell my safety
you cover this I'm going this time it's
a man on the man every time you play the
game you never change
it's about winning 101 batters twice to
fight this I will fight the fight one of
six doesn't define who you are what the
[ __ ] you are is what you do with you one
in six what the man do a fight cool just
everything you got today
no because you say go but because when
this thing is you have a bug with a call
for life little dude is everything your
head that's why you play as a rape
that's why you find it's a rape that's
why no matter what nobody on outside
stairs fight your fight baby found a way
to fight his fight raises don't buckle
I started changing because my father
left me
the only way I can get little pain
sometimes was Justin push-ups and
sit-ups inside pastime for the next
decade Ray's father was rarely a part of
his life then in 1990 his sophomore year
in high school a coach looking to
motivate ray handed him a yearbook from
1975 that listed the school's athletic
records and when he handed me the book
he said you didn't know what to do with
this I lived in the first piece I said
that's my father that's not daddy and I
flipped the next page and saw his name
wasn't unwanted every record I was so
pissed off I said I got it I said I got
it I'm gonna go through these books and
I will train so hard that I will never
stop say his name is he raced they have
to be at the day of day master
and every time his record fall I'll call
my garage I was scratching scratching
thought away said that's one down that's
one down
maybe the white scissors is one on one
down whatever whatever whatever let's
order the Kraus do find your way to an
office and see that another team
how about you turn out to be coming of
him
I saw lanes how did you treat you have
found out a way it's not waste I'm sorry
it's awesome
see God gives us a lot of things in life
but it's a couple of things he don't
give us and time some he gives no that's
the one thing no matter people did your
wife's I wanted my watch but we don't
clock time with the mop up with your
phone I look at my time normally so of
question is how much time you always I
think for I'm trying to make money years
ago I gave up on entertain clothes years
ago 14 years since it's step in anything
that doesn't but friend where I'm trying
to go that's what you got put in every
decision you've made
there's digital citizen and things we're
all sweet random but comes with us you
gotta get rid of so these songs Asians
came in half of it there's a keyboard
without love stands the reason why what
you got
or sacrifice to me
what promises you've gotta make see
themself so become gray
reading same thought process previous
lifestyle
it's what you live
why is it important for you to give back
my mom what do you mean isn't it's it's
not a secret we we didn't have much we
didn't have much but she showed me a
model and and I filed to follow that
model and then model is you know I don't
need to give you everything you want I
just make I got to make sure you have
everything you need and my mom gave more
to people when we didn't have and all
she did was give give give give I mean
I'm telling you we were completely broke
growing up completely and to see her
given to see what she was built for that
state she still was a giver so she was
your mind all right from the start I'm
inside my greatest I've had a lot of
people that I admire but my greatest
role model on this earth is my mom
because what she taught me no man could
ever give me
give it yeah give him give him don't
ever stop giving and and you know the
Good Book says giving to the poor's like
lending to God himself so when you start
to understand sure sure and you start to
really added to your life it becomes a
purpose so my purpose of giving became a
purpose and rest of my life to figure
out different ways to get up different
ways to help different ways to encourage
different ways to speak life into people
and so that's what my whole vision
started to open up and say wow you know
what the gain was great but the grant
the game is actually a platform for me
to really be able to use what God has
given me which is my ability to give my
infrastructure what I wanted to see
myself I wrote I wrote I write
everything down and I see everything so
I got books and books and books from
years that now I go back and pull out
and I'm like wow you said this an old
nine No and now you live in it you also
claim yeah okay and you see it and you
see it and that's one thing I share with
guys I'm like listen write down you're
gonna write it you know let's just
subconscious mind be the leader of you
you know I'm sad trusted because what
you think is your subconscious mind
ultimately what you're gonna live
you see and that's that's when God says
right division he said make it plain he
didn't say even prior to 5,000 rest Hey
you just said write it make it plain so
you can see it so you can visually see
where you want to go in your next steps
and so for me I did that a lot and I
still do it if life wants to end right
now how would you be remembered like how
will somebody think about you every
footstep that's ever took in why you've
been on this earth
it's accounted for and will be counted
one day we all gotta face judgement day
one day so I found out very early in
life
ain't no there are no breaks in life my
greatest pain I've ever had in my entire
life I'm 39 years old I'll be 40 in
three weeks and for the first time for
the first time in my life 33 years old
39 33 and the first time actually
chance to meet my father and it bothered
me so much because I still look at
myself in the mirror sometimes I said my
little lamb
now the question remains why inside of
me there was a burn that has never
stopped burning there was a crime that I
made up in my mind the first time I fell
on my knees I never forget it I'm
praying and some fall on my knees
and I was just really canary and I fell
on my knees and the first time I heard
God's voice I said can you hear me now
but I'm asking to hear daddy's voice I'm
every Christmas I'm sitting at
Christmases with a bag packed I got a
t-shirt in the bag of one pair of jeans
I got a toothbrush but no toothpaste and
I'm saying daddy gotta come today daddy
gotta come this Christmas daddy never
came daddy's never came so I had a
decision to make at a very early age
what I fold or what I make up my mind to
be remembered forever
I made up my mind
to be remembered for
I did it
I did it you know what I did I did it my
way
I did it my way
and today
I need a young man to change that I had
a tude of life and do it their way they
are somebody
sitting in this audience that has one
thing to do
the moment you leave here
make up in your mind that I'm a
different person
make up in your mind that there's
something way greater than me everybody
in this room this thing could have a
real change in somebody's life by the
way you live your own life
no pain lasts always no pain I can do
all these I can do all things through
Christ who strengthens me at middle
linebacker from Miami number 52 Ray
Lewis
why are we out there to play a football
game tonight boys
this'll be a great night tonight if it
were on the image I get tired with it I
got too much
a champion is not easy but you require
you tonight is the night we ride for the
camouflage humble with brothers inside
here we come with the blue we own this
hail a date well that was the blue with
all these here hey it's the man's day
every night now as you know that some
man staying the night he'll wake up here
we come
get the latest game now don't get
nervous kill some people now it's gonna
be a football game tonight now football
game here
okay I'm video all right let's go baby
Oh y'all thought I was did not easy
oh no
feel feel hurt this auto machine
don't tell my job you can't run from
this you can't run from this
they came let them have for me tonight
they got to see me they see if they can
world without nobody touching and I'm
told ma let's become great you know what
we do I think everybody watching tonight
so I tell you what if you can't find
tonight you're the role business
catalyst thank you guys so much for
watching we make this video because Mark
asked us to if there's anyone that you
will like asked to feature please leave
the comment below I'd also love to know
which of Ray Lewis says top ten rules
meant the most to you leave in the
comments and we'll join in the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe it's this handy okay
no no this has me together
bling I will see you soon